pour la sixième année consécutive 24
clubs seniors venus des quatre coins de
l'île se rencontrent pour un challenge
sportif activités affaire n'a fait le
vélo et on a fait la course et on va
faire des ballons le gros ballon loi
relancer les ballons et les ballons et
on est deux noté sur dix c'est sur un an
des bons on dépend au regroupement près
de 2500 personnes âgées ont fait le
déplacement à petite-ile pour assister à
cette manifestation
et pendant que les plus entraînés se
mesure à la marche rapide
d'autres prennent le temps de découvrir
le village santé bien-être
la deuxième c'est bien ce que vient nous
déjà j'ai eu ces personnes-là l'année
passée pour faire les invités sur cette
journée le conseil départemental des
jeunes accompagne les seniors sur les
différentes activités
un moyen également de créer du lien
social
c'est très important pour nous de
pouvoir aider tout simplement maximum de
personnes parce que cette année et est
très centré sur l'aide à la personne et
le partage est aujourd'hui pour voir
être là-haut channing des seniors c'est
en même temps un un avantage pour
favoriser et faire rendre plus forts les
liens intergénérationnels
est ce qu'on a vraiment voulu valoriser
cette année et ben c'est peut-être pour
conclure à une année de partage à plus
de 60 ans ces seniors ont bien compris
l'importance de pratiquer une activité
physique le sport comme thérapie pour
lutter contre la perte d'autonomie et
l'isolément des personnes âgées
d'ailleurs c'est l'objectif de notre
association en ce sens que au départ il
ya eu la création dans les 24 communes
du département de centre d'activités
physiques pour les seniors de plus de 60
ans à raison de une
voire trois séances par semaine ça c'est
le point fort c'est le maillon fort de
l'organisation puisque cette pratique
régulière permet d'assurer pour les
seniors de plus de 60 ans un bon
maintien physique